It is possible to win a game of chess in just
two moves.
A reservoir of water was discovered 400 miles
beneath the Earth's surface that contains
three times as much water as all the oceans
put together.
The number of Crayola colours available doubles
every 28 years.
During the California gold rush, water cost
more than gold.
Charles Darwin's last book was called The
Formation of Vegetable Mould through the Action
of Worms.
When he enlisted in the army, J. R. R. Tolkien's
son Michael put down his father's profession
as 'Wizard'.
If Bill Gates gave his entire fortune to the
US government, it would only cover the national
deficit for 15 days.
1 in 10 Icelanders will publish a book at
some time in their life.
Paganini was the fastest violinist ever. He
was recorded playing 12 notes per second.
Spraying dirty clothes with vodka makes them
smell better because vodka kills the odor-causing
bacteria.
The world's oldest rose bush is 1,000 years
old.
The hairy frog, often called the “Horror
Frog” has a unique defence system. When
threatened it breaks bones in its toes and
forces them through its skin to create claws.
The Lord of the Rings holds the record for
the greatest number of false feet used in
a single movie: 60,000.
There are currently 1,397 known asteroids
capable of causing 'major devastation' if
they hit the Earth.
There are 177,147 ways to tie a tie.
A group of hackers once took down Papa John's
website because their pizza was late.